and first this morning florida governor
ron desantis continues to fight the
power grabs ineptitude and
unconstitutional rulings of this white
house earlier this week he called the
florida legislature back for a special
session to address the federal vaccine
mandates to create protections for
floridians who risk losing their jobs he
is also looking to help alleviate the
supply chain log jams in california by
offering companies incentive packages to
reroute their ships to florida's ports
joining me right now in this exclusive
is the governor of florida governor it's
good to have you thanks very much for
being here this morning
good morning
tell me first about the log jams that
we're seeing in california we've got
about 160 ships sitting there idle
unable to uh drop off products that's
why we've got empty shelves across the
country what can you do in florida
well maria we're really proud of of our
seaport since i've been governor we've
invested about a billion dollars uh into
modernizing them and making even making
them even more effective so we have
capacity so if there are ships that are
idled off the west coast and actually
there's some off savannah on the east
coast as well uh we've already had some
from savannah be rerouted we can accept
that we have more capacity and they made
a big deal maria recently about
california ports would start doing 24 7.
we always do 24 7 in florida and so we
have multiple options each individual
port can offer companies incentive
packages to be able to do it obviously
that's a good thing for florida because
we're driving more economic activity in
our state and we've been doing very well
but it's also good for the country to be
able to alleviate these log jams because
to have shortages continue to pile up
and especially as we get into the
christmas season this drive inflation
even higher i mean it's a huge problem
and so florida can step up
and help be a partial solution to this
really national crisis we want to do it
so tell me more about the economy in
florida you said that you have been
creating jobs you know there were
reporters mocking you over the last six
months for your stance on uh ensuring
there was freedom and liberty for
floridians and yet now we turn around
and we see what's happened in florida
with job creation what can you tell us
so september the nation as a whole
reported 195 000 new jobs uh florida's
the state numbers came out this past
week florida's share of that was 84 500
of the 195 000. uh if you look at august
2021 and look at our hotel revenue
compared to august of 2019 pre-covered
we were up 11 over that the nation as a
whole was down five percent compared to
2019 pre-covet and so we have been able
to protect hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of jobs thousands of small
businesses and we've provided more and
more opportunity we have 400 to 500 000
job openings right now in florida you go
back when covet first started everyone
thought because we have such a
service-based and tourism-based economy
that we would be having massive problems
for years to come and we were able to
make sure that we protected people's
right to work and business is right to
operate and the result is we've really
been leading the way now in terms of
these economic numbers even in the face
of a lot of hostile trends coming out of
washington dc
yeah and we haven't seen any of those
hostile reporters report on any of the
facts in florida that you're talking
about look the president is still trying
to you know cut down the power of
governors uh last week he said that he
would uh send the national guard in
there to help with the uh supply uh
log logjam and then the white house had
to walk it back
so i ask you because the national guard
is the purview of governors the white
house is saying requesting the use of
the national guard at the state level is
under the purview of governors
and we are not actively pursuing the use
of the national guard on a federal level
after he said he would
would you governor desantis consider the
national guard
well we have the we have the logistical
know-how and capacity with our port so
if the supply chain you can bring it
we'll handle it there will be no need uh
to do that in florida because uh we're
modernized we're ready to go
if you're gonna start talking about
national guard what he should be doing
is sending them to the southern border
to get that under control because that's
a catastrophe month after month we see a
hundred two hundred thousand people
coming illegally he inherited a policy
under donald trump which was effective
and now it's a total disaster and so
he's always criticizing governors he's
criticizing florida texas
but that's his job to secure our country
and he's failed to do so
meanwhile these vaccine mandates are
clearly unconstitutional and now you've
got first responders quitting in droves
we're going to speak with one of them
who's who just lost his benefits later
on in the program a firefighter from
seattle but look at look at some of
these mandates and how they're causing
havoc because the health systems across
the country are already at crisis levels
and now nurses are saying look i have
religious regions i have other reasons
that i don't want to be forced to take
the shot so they're walking off the job
military uh
if you get discharged in the military
with a dishonorable discharge it's
almost equivalent to being treated like
a felon you can't work again your police
unions are resisting in chicago there
will be fewer police on the streets
already a situation that has crime
surging what what are you doing with
regard to these
vaccine mandates in florida governor
well fortunately uh we've been able to
put fight back very effectively uh
against mandates imposed by for example
local governments against police fire
maria these people we've been hailing as
heroes the nurses we've said have been
heroes this whole time they've been
working day in and day out they never
they couldn't do their job on zoom they
had to be there and they did it and they
did it with honor and integrity now you
have people that want to kick them out
of their job
over this shot which is basically a
personal decision and you're right what
biden's doing is unconstitutional he
does not have the authority to do this
but what it will do on a practical level
in addition to being unconstitutional in
addition to be taking away people's
personal choices
is it will wreak havoc in the economy
because even if a small percentage of
these folks end up losing their jobs or
voluntarily walking away
you're going to have huge disruptions in
medical in logistics in law enforcement
and so in florida our policy is very
clear we're going to have a special
session and we're going to say nobody
should lose their job based off these
injections it's a choice you can make
but we want to make sure we're
protecting your jobs and your
livelihoods
yeah not only that but in a situation
where there's crime spiking across the
country the president of the union
police union in chicago is estimating
that 3
200 chicago police are defying the
vaccine and they will be off the job
that means off the streets what is that
doing to the american people and their
feeling of safety it's very concerning
uh your thoughts on on where this is
going i mean is he just trying to insist
that this is a law so that companies
follow before it could actually be you
know abdicated and and and uh confirmed
to be unconstitutional
well first i think it's important to
point out on a scientific basis most of
those first responders have had coveted
have recovered so they have strong
protection uh and so i think that
influences their decision on a lot of
this that they have already had it and
recovered uh and so they're they're
making no accommodations for that
they're still pretending like that
doesn't even exist uh and so that's
really really troubling when you see
that but i can tell you maria and
florida not only are we going to want to
protect the law enforcement and all the
jobs we're actually actively working to
recruit out of state law enforcement
because we do have needs in our police
and our sheriff's departments so in the
next legislative session i'm going to
hopefully sign legislation that gives a
five thousand dollar bonus to any out of
state law enforcement that relocates in
florida so nypd minneapolis seattle if
you're not being treated well
we'll treat you better here you can feel
important needs for us and we'll
compensate you as a result
well there's a reason businesses and
hedge funds are moving to florida as
well as the democrats are negotiating
tax increases no state income tax there
governor thanks very much for being here
we'll keep watching the developments we
appreciate your time this morning
thanks maria